Robert Spencer here for Jihadwatch, a
program of the David Harowitz Freedom
Center and for the Center for Security
Policy with the reason why the struggle
against jihad terrorism has gone on for
15 years since the September 11th, 2001
terror attacks and is likely to go on
for a great deal longer. During the
recent 15th anniversary commemorations
of 9/11, among all the reminiscences and
eulogies and encomia, virtually no one
attempted to explain why this war has
taken so long. There's a simple reason
this topic wasn't discussed. Among our
political and media elites, no one knows
the answer. No one wants to admit that
this war isn't just 15 years old. It is
1,400 years old. Even the most dire
estimates of exactly how long this is
going to take have fallen wide of the
mark. General David Petraeus said in
2010 that it could take another 10 years
to defeat the Afghan insurgency. Now, do
you really think the Taliban is likely
to be disbanded and Afghanistan likely
to be a stable, functioning republic by
the year 2020?
In 2007, Britain's security chief,
Admiral Lord Alan West, said that it
could take 30 years to defeat terrorism
in the United Kingdom. Do you really
think that by 2037, Britain will be
peaceful and free of jihad terrorists?
The very idea is preposterous. And it is
preposterous for the same reason that 15
years after 9/11, no one knows why this
strange war has lasted so
long. Well, West said more in that 2007
interview. He stated, "I now realize
that we are talking about a generation,
and by that I would say 30 years. That
doesn't mean necessarily that we're
going to stay at a severe level of
threat for all those years, but to be
able to say one has absolutely changed
the mindset and thought of people is
going to take a generation." Now, Lord
Alan West nailed the answer there, but
nobody seemed to notice because nothing
nothing whatsoever is being done in
Britain or anywhere else to, as West
said, change the mindset and thought of
people. And that is why 15 years after
9/11, the West is weaker and more
vulnerable than ever. The entirety of
the western intelligencia, the totality
of our political and media elites
steadfastly refuse to acknowledge
exactly what the mindset and thought of
terrorists really is and where it comes
from. Because of that refusal, policies
that don't deal with the actual problem
keep being applied and reapplied at the
cost of thousands of American lives,
billions of American dollars, and we
have nothing to show for this
expenditure besides a sharp and
continuing loss of American power and
prestige. The jihadis who struck the US
on September 11th, 2001, have made such
immense advances since then, not because
they're strong or clever or capable, but
because we are weak, short-sighted, and
irresolute. Resolute, not fighting them,
but in maintaining our denial about who
they are and what they want. The denial
is so complete that we have taken
numerous steps to actually enable them
to achieve their goals. The billions
gifted to the Islamic Republic of Iran
and the welcoming of the massive Muslim
migrant influx are just two of the most
recent examples. On the 15th anniversary
of the 9/11 attacks, instead of stories
about the jihad threat and how it can be
defeated or at least contained, the
media posted articles that would give an
uninformed observer the impression that
it was 3,000 Muslims who were killed on
9/11. The media preoccupation on the
9/11 anniversary was almost entirely
with Muslims as victims. AOL had a
headline, "Muslim Americans still
struggle with hate crimes 15 years after
9/11." The Huffington Post lamented,
"For many Muslims, especially those born
after September 11th, Islamophobia seems
to be a fact of life." And the
Washington Post ran a piece by
Representative Keith Ellison, the Muslim
congressman from Minnesota, saying, "I'm
the first Muslim in Congress. I believe
America can beat Islamophobia. 15 years
after 9/11, American Muslims have seen
both progress and peril. Now, after Fort
Hood and Boston and Garland and
Chattanooga, San Bernardino, Orlando,
Paris, Brussels, Nice, New York, and St.
Cloud, and so very many others, this
myopia is ludicrous to the point of
being grotesque. And it is the key
reason why this war drags on 15 years
after 9/11. Millions unthinkingly accept
the dogma that to speak honestly and
accurately about the jihadis motives and
goals is to descend into racism and
bigotry and to endanger innocent
Muslims. 15 years after jihadis murdered
nearly 3,000 Americans, it is still
almost unheard of for there to be an
honest discussion of jihadi motives and
goals in the mainstream. The free West
is dug in, wholeheartedly committed to
denial, willful ignorance, and policies
that are self-defeating to the point of
suicidal. In light of that, the wonder
is not that this war has lasted so long,
but that we have held out so long.
Unless the political landscape changes
considerably, and this denial is
decisively rejected and discarded, much
darker days are coming. I'm Robert
Spencer.